el mundo dio la bienvenida al 2022 entre
celebraciones uno de los primeros países
en saludar al nuevo año fue australia
que con su tradicional espectáculo de
fuegos artificiales iluminó la bahía de
sydney las grandes reuniones volvieron
también a corea del norte para despedir
al 2021 miles de personas se convocaron
en pyongyang respetando el uso de
mascarilla espectáculos que horas más
tarde también se pudieron ver en
ciudades como dubai y su festival
pirotécnico desde el rascacielos burj
khalifa ya en europa madrid despidió la
nochevieja comiendo las tradicionales
doce uvas en la puerta del sol con la
esperanza de dejar atrás también la
pandemia
primero que se acabará la pandemia en
que llegamos ya con normalidad en parís
aunque hubo celebraciones en los campos
elíseos las restricciones a causa de la
ola de contagios y tienen notar
y en londres la buena noticia fue el
regreso de las campanadas en el 'big
ben' aunque también muchas celebraciones
quedarán suspendidas donde se rozó casi
la normalidad fue en río de janeiro
miles de personas se agolparon en la
playa de copacabana para ver los fuegos
artificiales y saludar al nuevo año con
los mejores deseos
agrada mi esposa está embarazada nuestro
deseo es que ella esté sana que seamos
muy felices en el 2022 y que todos nos
vaya muy bien
en eeuu ciudades como nueva york o las
vegas' realizaron sus tradicionales
festejos con restricciones parciales
también y con la esperanza de que este
2022 sea el año que le dé la bienvenida
de regreso a la normalidad